today on the matt well show recent
tragedies both here and in canada reveal
the utter insanity of left-wing
so-called criminal justice reform
policies also the white house press
secretary has publicly called out for
her own past comments questioning the
integrity of our elections how dare she
a gender affirming doctor so-called
admits that um kids who are put on
puberty blockers will never have proper
sexual function as adults never the
media says that if you don't like the
new lord of the rings series it's
because you are of course racist and
jennifer lawrence is worth 160 million
dollars lives in a mansion in beverly
hills but as she explained in an
interview that doesn't mean she isn't
oppressed all of that and more today on
the matt walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
you know some states now have laws that
say as early as the 2030 model year new
vehicles will have to be electric in
order to be registered cars with
internal combustion engines will only be
able to get license plates if they were
built before the end of the 2020s which
means that people are going to keep
repairing and driving their old cars for
generations it also means you'd better
go to rockauto.com right now and order
all the parts for to properly maintain
and repair your car your great grandkids
might be driving that car someday so you
better take care of it rockauto.com has
been in the auto parts business for 20
years family-owned their goal is to make
auto parts available and affordable to
keep you safe on the road rockauto.com
online parts catalog is incredibly easy
to use you can search all the parts
available for your specific car suv
truck whatever you drive with photos
specs and installation tips not only
will they have the part you need but
they'll usually give you
several trusted brands to choose from so
you get a great selection as well
rock autos kits are popular because they
bundle together all the parts you need
for a successful repair you don't get
halfway through installing a timing belt
only to discover that you need another
pulley professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers always pay the same
price which are reliably low for
everyone so go to rockauto.com right now
and get breaks shocks carpets wipers
headlights mirrors mufflers lug nuts
anything you need at rockauto.com and be
sure to write walsh in their how did you
hear about us box so they know that i
sent you
at age 14 miles sanderson of the
canadian province of saskatchewan
started doing cocaine and as the parole
board would later put it his criminal
offending began
at about that time and continued with
quote no significant breaks for nearly
two decades as an adult
sanderson would go on to rack up 59
criminal convictions many of his
convictions were for
violent crimes like in 2017 when he
burst into his ex-girlfriend's home uh
making threats and forcing the children
uh and his ex-girlfriend uh to flee to
an upstairs bathroom while he beat on
the door and put holes in it and then he
went outside and threw a cement block
through a windshield
about six months later he got drunk and
stabbed two guys and then beat another
one unconscious and left him in a ditch
a couple of days later he made threats
against an employee at a store and said
that he would murder the guy and burn
down his parents house two months after
that he got into a violent standoff with
police assaulting one of the cops by
punching and kicking him in the head
even after he'd been detained and cuffed
these are just a few of the crimes that
he committed he had over 50 other
convictions for crimes ranging from
assault to assault with a weapon to
robbery and everything in between
eventually he wound up in prison where
he spent time in the prison's quote
healing lodge and was quickly granted
parole in the summer of 2021 immediately
he violated the terms of his parole and
after only four months on the outside
found himself back behind bars in
february of this year
he appeared before the parole board
again and he asked them to reverse their
decision to put him back in prison
sanderson along with
already having violated his parole was
also officially classified as a
high-risk offender specifically was
determined that he was a high risk to
commit domestic violence
and violent crime in general
sanderson's parole supervisor for this
reason recommended that he remain behind
bars but the members of the parole board
said that they were impressed with the
fact that sanderson had quote made
progress on his healing journey and they
were happy that he had quote made
arrangements for a therapist and they
were optimistic that he could quote make
the journey towards a pro-social life
moreover they determined that his life
of crime was not really his fault it was
due to trauma that he'd suffered from
quote the
intergenerational impacts of residential
schools neglect exposure to familial and
community substance abuse your own
substance abuse issues exposure to slash
experiencing domestic violence during
your childhood family fragmentation lack
of education and loss of culture
spirituality
they determined that he did not
therefore present an undue risk to
society and they declared quote the
board is satisfied that your risk is
manageable in the community if you live
with your
redacted so live with a certain family
member maintain sobriety and employment
and continue with developing supports
including getting therapy
so sanderson was released
he immediately violated his parole again
stopped reporting to his parole officer
and next thing you know he's on the land
he's off the radar completely for four
months until
this past weekend when he popped up
again
along with his brother damian sanderson
and went on a stabbing spree
murdering 10 people and wounding 18
others
and he's still on the run as we speak
his brother damian was found dead after
the stabbing spree possibly murdered by
miles himself
if miles is caught
uh caught alive and arrested again which
they think he probably committed suicide
but if he is caught and alive and
arrested again under canadian law he
will automatically be eligible for
parole after 25 years he's only 32.
that puts him out in the street before
he turns 60.
in canada you can murder 10 people and
still be released back into society
it is impossible to get a life sentence
for any crime in canada no matter what
you do
as miles proved it's nearly impossible
to get even a moderate sentence i mean
he committed 59 crimes and still hadn't
earned more than a comparative slap on
the wrist
now 10 people are dead
at the me at the hands of a man who we
were told by the parole board
presented no undue risk to society
now this story is not getting very much
attention in the american press as you
might
expect and that's not because it
happened in canada
it's rather because the whole saga every
bit of it from start to finish
exposes every left-wing narrative about
crime exposes and invalidates
reveals the absurdity of these
narratives
here we have a repeat violent offender
from a supposedly oppressed minority
group because he's uh he has indigenous
heritage
which by the way in canada that is also
according to the criminal code in canada
they have to take that into account so
if an indigenous person commits a
violent crime then they have to take
into account that he's indigenous and
oftentimes he'll get a lighter sentence
because well he's indigenous so it's
okay
so repeat offender
oppressed minority group supposedly
given chance after chance after chance
and yet utterly determined to inflict as
much damage on society as possible and
finally he goes on a mass killing spree
and does this in a country where guns
are illegal
because apparently you don't need a gun
to kill mass amounts of people
miles and damien didn't need guns anyway
their victims certainly could have used
them but the victims were disarmed in
fact prime minister justin trudeau had
just declared a couple of months earlier
you might remember this clip a couple
months earlier he said that self-defense
is not a human right
if you're attacked by a violent scumbag
in canada it is your responsibility to
simply die
and 10 people fulfilled their uh duty in
that respect
as justin trudeau demanded
now canada's gun laws and criminal
justice laws are totally
insane
they're literally designed to get
innocent people killed
and they have succeeded in that regard
but our situation down here in the
states isn't much better as we get
closer to canadian level madness every
single day innocent people die in our
country every single day for the sake of
giving brutal dirt bags their second and
third and fourth and fifth and sixth and
seventh chances
speaking of which a young woman named
eliza fletcher is one of the most recent
human sacrifices to be offered up on the
altar of compassion for criminals
fletcher was 34 years old a mother of
two small children a kindergarten
teacher
on friday morning she went jogging and
never returned two nights ago her so a
couple of nights after she went she went
missing her body was found dead
brutalized
lying in the yard of an abandoned home
her clothes had been removed and
discarded in a plastic garbage bag
nearby a man named cleotha abstain has
been charged with abducting and killing
fletcher and it will not surprise you to
learn that abstinent likes sanderson
is a career criminal with convictions
for assault robbery rape
all of that on his record
in fact in the year 2000 he was sent to
prison for 24 years for kidnapping and
aggravated
robbery so he had done exactly this
thing before now you might be doing the
math in your head and saying well
24 years
since 2000 why is he out of prison well
he was actually released into in 2020 he
was released four years
another criminal who according to the
parole board i guess uh didn't you know
present an undue threat to society
well he made it two years after being
led out of jail before he committed the
exact same crime again
only this time adding murder and
possibly
given the fact that the victim's clothes
were removed other unspeakable acts as
well though that hasn't been
confirmed yet
cleotha abstinent was given another
chance
actually given a lot of chances
and now two young children will grow up
without a mother because of that
this is happening all across the country
at an increasing rate
in all over 75 percent of criminals
released from prison end up back in
prison after committing more crimes
75
which means that any time a criminal is
released from jail it is statistically
almost certain
there's at least a three-quarters chance
that this person's gonna commit another
crime victimize another person end up
back in june
has this led to a decrease in the rate
at which these parasites are unleashed
back onto society no in fact it's been
the exact opposite
as more and more innocent people fall
victim to these to these repeat
offenders the powers that be have
doubled down promising to fill our
communities with even more of these
crooks and delinquents
john fetterman for example has called
for the mass release
of convicts who are serving life
sentences in prison and by the way uh
life sentence in prison this is not one
of those we always hear about the
mythological people that are
in prison because they you know had a
little bit of weed or something and they
were next you know they get they get 10
years in prison supposedly you know life
sentence uh it's not for weed we could
tell you that but he wants to release a
lot of them let's listen to that
we have a catastrophic bottleneck in our
prisons of over 5 000 men and women
condemned to die in prison
and many of them i believe personally
are deserving of a second chance
catastrophic bottleneck he says in fact
john fetterman has been more specific
talking about this and has said that he
wants to release up to one-third of the
prisoners who are serving life sentences
because of the um bottleneck
there are too many people who've done
things so horrible that they earned life
sentences because of it and the solution
says fetterman and also says nearly
every other elected democrat in the
country is to
release these people back into our
communities um
and uh so that so that you know the the
catastrophe in our prison can become a
catastrophe right outside our front
doors
that's exactly what's happened with
violent crime rates rising rapidly all
across the country
now what makes this crisis so especially
infuriating
is that
unlike other problems we face as a
society i mean there are some problems
that are complicated and difficult and
there is not an easy solution
this is not one of those problems
there's actually an easy simple solution
and it's a solution that almost nobody
is talking about among our elected
officials and that's on the right and
the left
okay because keep in mind this is not
just the democrats
now we we talk about the democrats i
just said democrats but it's also
republicans
there are lots of republicans
including the last republican
administration who were all uh on board
for prison reform which means
taking more people out of prison and
putting them on the streets
there are very few republicans offering
the real solution which is this
arrest violent criminals
put them in prison
and keep them there
now if there are concerns about the
sustainability of such a system if
there's a concerns about uh about
overcrowding and bottlenecks well
there's a solution for that too
here's what it is
you take the worst of the bunch the most
violent and despicable guys like cleotha
abstinent
and uh what you do is again it's very
very simple
you you take them out of their prison
cells
and you bring them up onto a platform
and you put a rope around their necks
and then you hang them from it until
they're dead
and then you take their bodies and you
bury them in a grave marked only by
their inmate number and you let society
forget that they ever existed
because when you do things like this you
don't even get to be remembered by
society
we bury you in the ground and try to
forget about you
now this is called capital punishment of
course you may have heard of it it's
still used in some states but should be
used in every state and it should be
used much more often than it is
a society with a strong sense of justice
a clear understanding of right versus
wrong
and a society which values innocent
lives like eliza fletcher
will necessarily treat violent crime
with this kind of severity it is not
blood lust or vengeance it is justice
it's also realism as it acknowledges
that some people through their own
behavior have become an undue burden on
society
and they've given us no choice but to
relieve ourselves of the burden through
the only means available i mean if
you're such a burden on society that we
can't even put you in prison
then then there's only one other
solution
the point we have to understand here
and the way that we should be framing
this discussion and talking about it
is that releasing violent criminals or
giving them lenient sentences
is not a decision made in a vacuum
everything in life is a trade-off
and that's especially the case here so
when somebody like abstinent or or
sanderson is sent back into the free
world
again and again and again and again
again
the system
that released those men is making a
trade it's not just they're not just
doing it there's a trade here
they are trading eliza fletcher's safety
your safety my safety my children's
safety your children's safety for the
sake of this person's freedom
that's what they're saying
i mean think about the phrasing that
they that they used for sanderson in
undo it's not an undue risk to society
well it's not the same thing as saying
that it's not a risk
it's just not an undue risk
what does that mean well it means that
the parole board the system has declared
that yeah he's a risk i mean he's a high
risk actually so think about it how
could he be a high risk offender and yet
not an undue risk
how could he be classified as both at
the same time well because
he's a high risk
but it's a due risk
like it's a it's a it's a risk worth
taking is what they're saying in other
words
yeah there's a high risk that he's gonna
kill a bunch of people which he did but
it was a risk worth taking for his
freedom
that's what they're saying
the system declares that it is worth the
risk to your children's lives in order
to give
a heinous monster his 9th or 10th or
11th chance
but the people who make this trade on
our behalf a trade that none of us agree
to or want
are never made to defend the decision
or explain how they've arrived at this
moral calculation
they can't defend it
because all of this is
in the worst way
indefensible
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right this has really gotten out of
hand folks uh the sweet baby gang has
now started a petition calling for a
return to the flannels
and there's an actual change.org
petition
next thing you know there's going to be
a march on washington
and but this is really difficult for me
to understand because i'm being torn in
different directions i'm helplessly
caught in the middle
okay i am i am a i am utterly helpless
here
like yesterday after the show i i had
like a 30 minute conversation with my
producer shauna mckenna who are both
very pro blazer and anti-flannel i'll
tell you sean had like a whole
powerpoint presentation about about
about the blazer
but then i go home
and i find out that my wife is on team
plaid and and she's like
she's actually very everyone is very
serious about this and taking it very
seriously
she is like emotional about it and she
actually said this is what she said i'm
not making this up she said that you
know you know it's getting to be fall
now and so i go out and i see people
wearing plaid
and i see them wearing flannel and it
makes me sad
remembering when you used to wear
flannel and i'm like i'm not dead i'm
still i'm sitting right across from you
i can still wear flannels it's just
about the show
then she tells me that she actually sent
a text to our wardrobe person about this
issue so she has
entered into the
discussion meanwhile i'm sitting here i
don't have strong feelings about it like
i have strong feelings about almost
everything including things that don't
matter at all but
in terms of what i wear i don't care
that much
which is the whole reason i wore flannel
to begin with it's just because like
it's something you can throw on and you
don't need to iron it as much it doesn't
get as wrinkly at least as obviously
wrinkly so that's why i was wearing it
to begin with
so i'm sort of uh
stuck in the middle it's like the one
thing i don't care that much about
everyone is sort of in my ear about it
so here's what i'll say
start a gofundme
raise 50 000
for me personally to go in my pocket
and then i'll start wearing the flannel
again that's the solution
just kidding don't do that because i
forget i said that because they'll
actually do it don't do it that was a
joke but
i still haven't decided what the answer
is okay karen gene pearce she might have
an answer to this maybe someone should
ask her she uh she that's what we need
we need that we need a statement from
the white house on this issue she was
called out at the white house
press conference yesterday for her own
past comments
questioning the integrity of our
elections and uh
you know this is something that you
could do this is you could take any
democrat on the national stage and put
them on the spot like this because all
of them of course when donald trump was
elected in 2016 all of them were out
there saying that this is not legitimate
this is not right this is this you know
we got to abolish the electoral college
this is russia's everything election
interference all of them were saying
that every single one
uh karen jean-pierre was among them and
uh here's how she responded to that
question
the new attention on the mag of
republicans you tweeted
trump
stole an election i was waiting peter
when you were going to ask me that
question well here we go you tweeted
trump stolen election you tweeted brian
kemp stole an election if denying
election results
is extreme now yeah
wow so let's let's be really clear that
that comparison that you made is just
ridiculous i have been i have been well
you're asking me you're asking me a
question let me answer it and you said
ridiculous i was i was talking
specifically at that time of what was
happening with voting rights and the
what was in danger of voting rights
that's what i was speaking to at the
time
um
well it's this is
of course that's always their answer
this is ridiculous
are you saying that i should be held
accountable for my own words that i are
you suggesting that i should hold myself
to the same standard that i hold my
political opponents that's absurd and
the thing is that's not that's not a put
on that's not an act she really thinks
it's ridiculous
if for people on the left it is it is
actually absurd to them the very idea
that they should be held to the same
standard that they hold the rest of us
is it's just it's ludicrous
it doesn't even compute
well of course it's different it's me
saying this it's as opposed to you
and actually
you know we say this goes back to 2016
with them questioning elections
um and it wasn't just the presidential
election i mean they also we we know
that they stacey abrams is currently the
governor of uh of uh of georgia
according to them
but it goes back before 2016. i mean
they've been questioning the integrity
of every election they lost since at
least 2000.
i mean since at least the first bush
term
they've been questioning the integrity
of every election they lose
and it's not even just elections it's
whenever they lose
anything they they question the
integrity of the system that produced
that loss for them
supreme court
you know they could get
50 supreme court decisions in a row that
go their way then they get one that
doesn't and it's well the whole the
whole thing is rigged the whole system
needs to be changed abolish the supreme
court get rid of it
that's what they do that of course is
always the game
but to them it's not as i'm always
reminding people it's not a it is
not really a double standard it is one
standard which is
uh you know
they get to do what they want and
for us it's something different so it's
kind of one it is in a way one
consistent standard where they they are
the privileged and and they can act a
certain way but that doesn't apply to us
all right this is from daily wire an
interesting poll result here although
it to me it's kind of up in the air
whether you interpret this in a positive
or negative way i don't know it says
nearly one in four democratic voters
believe men can get pregnant according
to a new poll
the online survey conducted by wpa
intelligence from august 20 uh
22nd through the 25th found 22 percent
of democrats agreed with the statement
some men can get pregnant the percentage
rose when only including women and a
whopping 36 percent of white
college-educated female democrats
concurred
overall few americans think that men can
get pregnant uh but this is quoting from
the firm that did the poll but with 36
percent of a core democrat constituency
and one out of five democrat voters
believing this
one can see why democratic leaders
coddle the radical gender theory
movement
the poll underscores the left's growing
embrace of a radical gender theory that
biological sex does not dictate gender
now i i've sort of seen this paul just
came out this morning and daley white
reported we looked at some of the
reaction
and i've seen some people on the right
kind of kind of taking this in a
positive way and saying well it's so so
the majority of even democrats don't
believe that men can get pregnant
um so that's
a good sign i guess
i'm not sure i quite see it that way
still 22
will agree with the statement that some
men can get pregnant that is a given the
statement that they're agreeing to
okay if this was uh 22 of democrats
uh
you know only 22 percent of democrats
think that abortion should be legal with
no with no exceptions or something well
that i would say well that would be a
very good sign
22
agree with the statement that some men
can get pregnant
and one of the things about polls like
this is that you can't you can't you
can't go back
10 years 20 years and check what the
polls were saying back then because
nobody was polling this this topic at
all
which actually tells you everything you
need to know
it was it didn't occur to anyone to even
ask the question until
you know five seconds ago
but i think we would be pretty certain
that if this question was asked
i mean 10 years ago it gets a little
dicey 15 years ago 20 years ago you
asked this question and every single
person is saying
can men get pregnant no of course not
and then
what an even greater shame for
the democrats and female democrats in
particular
that there are more women on the
democrat side that will agree with that
statement than men
it's like
women
on the left
are more on board with being erased
than
the men are
college-educated female democrats in
particular
which kind of shows you uh
what a what a college education does for
you these days i mean you've got people
that go through
four years of college or even i mean how
many of these are grad students i'd like
to break it down that far
i want to see this poll again but now
show me so we've got college-educated
democrats and then and then and then
narrow it down to grads to i want those
with master's degrees and phd's
how many of them say that men can get
pregnant i bet you then it gets over
fifty percent
so you could spend four six eight
however many years
in higher education supposedly
and come out on the other end
with six-figure debt
but a a
less of a grasp on basic biology than my
kids have
here's uh kind of on the same subject
here's a pediatrician with a familiar
line about puberty blockers this is on
another pediatrician on tick tock now
once again obviously
goes without saying
for me to take this video and show it to
you is an act of terrorism and
incitement how dare i but here's what
she said
puberty blockers are used once puberty
has started but not when you're too far
along
and what they do is they just pause your
puberty where it's at
and that gives you time to further
explore your gender identity without the
extra pressure of developing in a gender
in which you might not feel comfortable
and then if you continue those puberty
blockers long enough then you can start
replacement therapy with the uh gender
identity hormone of your choice when you
reach usually around 15 or so or once
you've been on that puberty blocker for
at least a couple of years hope that
answers your question
yeah that's the the the account is
called ask the doctor or ask a doctor so
you know if you have any medical
questions you can go and ask this doctor
and she will simply lie to your face
with delusional insane dangerous
nonsense like what you just heard there
uh but but it's familiar nonsense at
this point especially if you've seen my
film what is a woman which you can go to
webbswoman.com if you haven't seen it
and watch it there um you are familiar
with this nonsense because it's the same
thing that i heard from uh
from several so-called experts that well
you could just pause
just pause it just put it on pause
uh a total lie of course and it and it
reveals again on the left
and we see this with a lot of what they
say about climate change and
environmentalism too we see it um you
know a slight slightly less
malignant form of it but still pretty
much
it which is this total
lack of respect for nature
as much as they talk about nature uh a
total lack of respect for it for the
power of
nature
and that includes human nature that
includes biology
so
you're treating the process
of human development
it's like a game
but you're talking about the the analogy
that uh one of the people i talked to
in what is a woman used is it's like
it's like it's music you could just
pause it and then pick up the next note
of the song
but really it's they're talking about it
like it is a game like it's a video game
you just hit the pause button and you
can freeze it right there and then come
back to it anytime and pick up right
where you left off
that's not how nature works
you're talking about
a system
in in human beings anyway that's
been in place
for millions of years and you think you
can
you can circumvent it like that that
easily just pop a pill
circumvent this process without any
downside whatsoever no side effects
you could take a pill and put someone
kind of freeze someone at the exact
moment of development they're currently
at and keep them there indefinitely
by the way if this was true
would this not be the the key to like
immortality basically
if that's true that you could just take
a pill and freeze your physical
development in place
and then resume it some other time then
i mean i guess you could take puberty
blockers you know someone could take
puberty bloggers for 60 years
and then when they're when they're
technically in their 70s they could pick
up with uh development again and end up
living in you know until they're like in
their
mid-100s
if that's how it worked but that is not
how it worked works at all
i mean what you can do is you can
essentially by poisoning these kids
and when you're using the drugs this way
off label in a way that they're not
meant to be used you're poisoning them
and you can stunt their growth
and you can mess with the biological
processes
but there are significant
side effects and we can't even really
call them side effects because they are
just they're the effects they're really
the intended effects
so here is um
a report in the post-millennial
with another name that might be familiar
to you if you've seen what is a woman
says that a recent talk at duke
university on trans and gender diverse
policies care practices and well-being
surgeon and trans affirming doctor
quote-unquote marcy bowers who
transitioned to the age of 38 admitted
that children who undergo transition
before puberty will never have adult
sexual function or experience orgasm
never
bower said an observation that i had
every single child who was or adolescent
who was truly blocked at tanner stage
two which is the beginning of physical
development
when hormones begin their work of
advancing a child to adulthood has never
experienced orgasm
i mean it's really zero
bower says
um
this raises huge and glaring red flags
about the concept of informed consent
reading now from post-millennial for
children and teens who are ushered in
transition um bowers proudly advertises
the fact that she
actually it's a it's a he this is a male
has both delivered two thousand babies
and performed two 2000 castrations on
biological men who identify as
transgender performing uh vaginoplasties
and is recognized as a pioneer in the
field of gender affirming surgery so
like i said we talked to marxie bowers
in uh in what is a woman
and this is the person who when we there
there are many disturbing parts of that
conversation
but there's also the person we taught
when when i when i asked him about um
the social contagion is there a social
contagion element to this the the fact
the fact that we've got so many kids all
of a sudden who are identifying as trans
when before it was almost non-existent
comparatively speaking
uh is that an indication of of
social contagion and
i think the exact quote quote was maybe
a teensy bit just a little bit
but here's bowers admitting
that when you give these drugs to a
child
you are forfeiting for the child
permanently
adult sexual function
and that does raise a question about
consent
i mean it doesn't simply raise a
question about consent it reveals that
there cannot be consent here because how
can a child
consent to foregoing something like that
you're talking to a pre-pubescent child
how can they possibly consent to
foregoing adult sexual function they're
forgoing something they've never
experienced they don't understand
and they're consenting to never having
it ever in their lives
same question with a with a 14 year old
girl who supposedly consents to having
her breasts removed and thereby con
consents supposedly to
um
never being able to breastfeed a child
yeah maybe when you're talking to a 14
year old girl it doesn't sound like a
big deal because being a mother is
nowhere on her radar
especially when she's in the midst of
all this gender confusion that's been
imposed on her
in many ways
so how can she
consent
how could she know what she's giving up
she can't
this is a decision that is being made
for these children that the the the
adult versions of those children will
have to live with
and by the way the people that are
actually making decisions they don't
have to live with the consequences
they're putting that on the child to
deal with
all right this is from uh the daily wire
it says elon musk is weighing in on the
new amazon series the lord of the rings
the rings of power and it sounds like
the billionaire tesla ceo is not a fan
tolkien is turning in his grave musk
tweeted monday in response to the series
which just released episodes uh on uh
two episodes last thursday almost every
male
character so far is a coward a jerk or
both
only galadriel is i guess that's a lord
of the rings character is brave smart
and nice
now this is part of a overall kind of
backlash against i guess against the
lord of the rings series daily wire has
also has this report there's been a lot
of hype leading up to amazon's lord of
the rings adaptation the rings of power
but now some fans are saying it's a huge
flop the series premiered the first two
episodes thursday currently has an 84
critic rating and a 36 audience rating
on rotten tomatoes this certainly isn't
the first time critics and viewers
disagreed on whether a show was a
triumph or a fail
but some reviewers are accusing fans of
being racist for their one star reviews
of course we knew that was going to
happen a writer for the hollywood
reporter likened these reviewers to
miserable little trolls who were
review-bombing the series simply because
casting directors chose to add black
actors into it
so this is this is the narrative now
that we're getting from the media i
haven't watched this show i have no
interest in watching it and i'm a fan of
lord of the rings actually but it's
because i'm a fan of lord of the rings
that i'm not going to watch amazon's
version of it and i and i
i said this from the very beginning the
first time they announced the series i
was warning everyone it's going to be a
disappointment it is going to disappoint
you because hollywood in the year 2022
does not have the
ability i mean it would it would be
in any era it would be very difficult
to make a lord of the rings series which
yes maybe it's based on some of
tolkien's work
but
you're basically telling your own story
and now we're gonna stack it up against
one of the classic fantasy novels of all
time fantasy series of all time
so in any era of hollywood
um that's a lot to ask
i mean you're almost doomed to fail
already
but especially in this era
it's just it's impossible
that the series can be good
uh they don't have the capacity to tell
these kinds of stories anymore
and when i say capacity i don't mean
from a financial perspective they got
all the money in the world it's been a
billion dollars
on this series
uh which
by the way you don't hear a lot of
complaints from from the left about that
you know they say about like elon musk
when he made an offer for twitter they
said well why don't you you could have
taken that money and solved world hunger
well amazon spent a billion dollars on a
on a tv show
how much world how much of world hunger
could they have solved with that
but they've got the money but they don't
have there's not the there's not the
the spiritual capacity to tell stories
like this anymore in hollywood
but the narrative is that uh the people
don't like the show because there are
some black actors in it
and of course because you know
the people that are watching lord of the
rings it's the first time they've seen a
black actor in a show and they're all
racist and so that's why they have a
problem with it
then you you go and you read the
audience reviews and what you see not
surprisingly is that almost all of them
don't like the show because they think
it's boring they don't like how it's
written and all of those things
i looked at some of the reviews i didn't
see one person complaining about the
fact that there's a black actor
now with that said
audiences at this point have a very low
tolerance for anything that even smells
woke
like the minute there's a hint of
wokeness
and of course just having a black actor
doesn't mean that you're trying to do
something woke
but the minute there's a hint of it like
if there's a hint
that they put a character in the show
just for for no re not because it
advances a story but just for diversity
concerns
the minute there's even a hint of that
audiences are repelled and for good
reason because we're sick of it
though i don't think that's the primary
complaint here all right here's before
we get to the comment section here's the
latest from uh
tick tock this is a an anti-white racist
who went viral
with this temper tantrum about white
people let's listen
i call y'all white people for what i see
y'all y'all are devils y'all are
parasites y'all are mosquitos and when
you look at a mosquito you see that
mosquitoes latch on to other life forms
drain the blood from that life form to
get nutrients so it can power
itself
that's exactly what y'all are because
every single thing that y'all do is to
drain the life out of everything
and when we look at the advent of y'all
devils
since the moment y'all were created
y'all have cause destruction
chaos
and deception on our earth
when we welcome y'all in to our kingdoms
our lands as eternal people what did
y'all do
y'all came in y'all caused destruction
your cause artications
amongst us as a people and amongst our
civilization
therefore we banish y'all we exalt y'all
from the kingdom
this is the true story
of the garden of eden
oh it's a true story huh
uh yeah white people caused altercations
but there were no alter there were no
altercations in um
in africa prior to white people showing
up there were no altercations
in the americas before the europeans
showed up there were no altercations at
all
because when
um
those
cultures were
killing and enslaving each other which
they all were but they did it i guess in
a peaceful way it wasn't
you know kind of like the mostly
peaceful blm right it wasn't there was
no altercation involved i'm not sure
exactly how that works
by the way
not to get too technical here but i'm
pretty sure that only uh female
mosquitoes bite and suck blood
so this also strikes me as a sexist
complaint from this guy
and uh
white people though he says are our
parasitic life form basically that have
brought
only misery to the world
which i guess you can see why they would
say that
you know white people are parasites who
brought misery to the world by
inventing antibiotics
inventing electricity
inventing space travel
the printing press
modern plumbing
computers
almost all of modern medicine
all of the technology that this guy uses
to complain about white people invented
by white people so here's my challenge
and this is serious this is a this is a
a real challenge here
for any anti-white racist like this guy
and there are a lot of them out there
here's my challenge if you're an
anti-white racist i challenge you
to go one single day
i mean even an hour of a day i i would
be impressed if you could do that but
let's let's be ambitious
go one day
without using anything that was given to
you by the race of people you despise
one day
can you do it
i don't think you can but prove me wrong
now let's get to our
comment section
do you know their name
they're the sweet baby gang
okay i have to do something here before
we get to the comments and hopefully
you'll bear with me i'm in a bind all
right um the bind even worse than the
flannel predicament so a couple of weeks
ago i i happened to show you a picture
that my five-year-old son drew of me uh
maybe you remember that and i showed it
to you because he made me look like a
character from nightmare before
christmas and um which he's not even he
hasn't even seen the movie
and i thought that was cool so you know
i showed you the picture well
last night i happened to mention to my
son that i showed
that picture that he drew of me on my
show my kids obviously don't watch my
show they have very little idea of what
i do for a living they've got very
little concept of it all they know is
that daddy is on tv
and also that random stranger sometimes
stop daddy to take pictures with him
that's the only thing they know
so uh he he was he was surprised by that
when i told him
that i showed the picture he was shocked
and he was thrilled and he was very
proud of himself rightfully so
and then and i didn't know he was doing
this at the time but he ran off and he
began furiously drawing more pictures
three more pictures in total
and he came and he put them in my my my
bag my briefcase and he and he asked me
to bring those to work and to show
everyone those pictures too
and he said that those pictures are even
better and he wants everyone to see them
to know what a good artist he is
so he says this to me and it's like what
a
what am i going to say to that he's so
excited and so proud and so i said yeah
sure buddy i'll i could do that at some
point and he said well no can you do it
tomorrow
and and and i said well yeah well we'll
see and he said dad could when you get
home can you show me the video of you
showing the drawing so i know you did it
and i said
yeah sure i could do that great
so he backed me into a corner folks
which is why and here's the clip that
i'm gonna this is where the this is the
this is the part of the clip i'm gonna
show him
um this is why i have to show you these
amazing drawings that my son made for me
we'll put them up on the screen so you
can see them uh you can see there's a
picture of me fishing
there's another one of me
and him and then there's another one of
me
i think we can all agree sweet baby gang
that uh this kid is truly a phenomenal
artist and what's even better i think is
that he has a knack for choosing great
subjects for his drawings
mainly because the subject is almost
always me
so
there you are there are the drawings
each one
better than the last can't we all agree
now
let's get to the comments cody says
i am sad in matt to hear that you have
not had anyone to talk about dinosaurs
for so long happy that your boys have
grown enough to discuss the fascinating
creatures with you if you ever need
someone else to talk to about them i
love dinosaurs and i'm here for you well
i appreciate that cody bentley says matt
bans multiple people from the show for
telling him how to dress
and groom himself and he says he's a man
of principle and then immediately
proceeds to tell us what razor we should
be using the hypocrisy well
in fairness to me i'm just doing as i'm
told there i mean it's not they are
great razors but as you know it's not
like i can really offer my my personal
endorsement of them but i do hear
they're great
um
let's see taimai shoes says matt needs
to add that red lighting during his
daily cancellation segment a couple of
walruses in the background oh the red
lighting from biden's speech that's
actually a really good idea
i hadn't thought about that but that is
that lighting is terrible for
presidential speech as has been
established
would be really good for daily
cancellation i do agree with you
question everything says i'm 65 and i
did not know what non-binary is i
thought it was computer talk not to
mention i'm a great grandmother and my
children my grandchildren and my
great-grandchildren have never talked
this way until their school attempted to
indoctrinate them into this insanity
well you know i'm i'm happy to hear this
response from someone
in their 60s uh because of of course
like you you lived
you know
a your whole life without anyone ever
talking about non-binary because that
concept didn't exist until it was
invented 15 seconds ago
and i have to tell you going back to my
film what is a woman
when we were out doing our man on the
street interviews at first i really
expected like i thought that we would
we'd stop a bunch of younger people and
people my age i don't know if they count
this younger
um and we would get a lot of people who
are just confused and talking about
non-binary and pansexual and the rest of
it
i thought though
that if we get anyone over the age of
like 50 certainly people in their 60s
and 70s and we stop them and talk to
them about this stuff they're gonna be
they're gonna have your reaction and say
what is this this is crazy
but it was quite depressing to find that
uh the confusion
spans all age groups largely
with some exceptions like in your case
ss says i'm probably going to get
roasted here but i'm going to say this
anyway because i think it's true and i
hope matt can be challenged by it i
agree with a lot of what matt walsh says
a lot of it most of it
here comes the butt
but the way in which he says it is very
often self-defeating if his goal is to
do anything other than preach to the
choir a case in point from this episode
matt says i hate these people
and only a few minutes later runs an ad
for a christian app that is listed among
other among other aims reducing the
sinful temptation to hatred i know the
typical rejoinder here is something
along the lines of these people don't
deserve kindness because they're
threatening our very way of life and so
on i've heard all that and i don't buy
it the reason is that jesus did not
respond this way to people and yes i'm
aware that he had harsh things to say
but go back and read them and you'll
find that they are not spoken to
those blinded by the world's sinfulness
and enslaved to it but to the religious
leader of his leaders of his day whose
failure to abide by god's revealed path
denigrated god's name what jesus said
explicitly is to love your enemies and
forgive those who persecute you uh
i accept most of that
the forgiveness part not so much
because
is it up to me now what was i referring
to yesterday when i said that i was
referring to adults who sexually
indoctrinate kids
who mutilate and drug kids that's what i
said when i said i hate these people
um it's not up to me to forgive them
okay now you could say i i forgive them
as a christian that's worthless that is
a there is worthless forgiveness
because you are not the person harmed
this sin was not committed against you
so you could forgive them all day long
what does that even mean i mean what
does it mean to forgive someone of a sin
they didn't commit against you but
against someone else namely a child
so forgiveness is a christian virtue it
is very important but you can only
forgive someone for things they've done
to you
things that you are affected by
if you're not affected then forgiveness
is
um
you know forgiveness is is is a
is something that happens again to
people who are if you are affected by it
now that said
does that let me off the hook entirely
no i it doesn't
you are correct we are called to love
our enemies we shouldn't go around
saying we hate people i i'm with you on
that
but i'm also being honest with you about
how i feel about it
um because i do have hatred for them i
really do and i'm just being totally
honest
not defending it being honest with you
that hatred is born from my love for the
children who are being harmed
that's where it comes from
um
if you are able to
regulate that do a better job of
regulating within yourself then that's
that's very good and you should be
commended for that
however my fear is that uh and i'm not
saying this is the case for you because
i don't know if it is or not i can't see
inside your heart
but
i i have noticed there are a lot of
christians who preach well we should
love our enemies
and we should love the people who do
horrible things to children
and yet for many of them it's not really
love you know it's at the very least
it's kind of a cheap love that they have
because it's more indifference like they
don't really care that much about it and
so they don't they don't feel
that rage within their souls
about the horrible things that are
being done to kids and to others they
don't feel that rage and anger uh they
don't feel it and so it's very easy for
them to say oh no we should we shouldn't
lash out in anger we should just be
loving
it's only worth something if you feel
the anger i mean if you understand just
how hideously horribly evil this is
and if you feel that and understand it
and yet are still able to regulate
yourself spiritually and emotionally
then again i commend you i can learn
something from you but
um
there's a lot of so-called christian
love in our culture that to me seems a
lot like indifference
which is why you get this from a lot of
churches and you hear you peace priests
and pastors get up there and they talk
about christian love all day long they
never even mention any of these things
they don't even acknowledge it
because they don't care and they're
indifferent to it
and so it's really easy for them to say
oh i love our enemies
well you don't even care about what our
enemies are doing to these to these kids
so
you had a caution for me
i accept that i have a caution for you
as well something to think about
well football season is upon us and my
colleagues bordering on friends over at
uh crane and company are hosting their
first ever fantasy football draft party
tonight if you're an anti-woke sports
fan and you haven't watched cranial
company on the daily wire yet then i
suggest you do so not just because it's
a great sports show that refuses to
virtue signal leftist politics but
because i will be competing
all season long to add daily wire
fantasy football champion to my twitter
bio as well i've got many accolades this
one is going to be the next that i add
every week i'll be going head-to-head
with the crane guys ben shapiro andrew
clavin morning wires john bickley and
even michael knowles whose sum of sports
knowledge is the new york yankees in the
90s so i think we're good there
make sure to follow our daily wire
fantasy league throughout the season by
watching cranial company mondays through
fridays and um i better not blow the
draft because the loser of this league
this is real we're actually doing this
if you lose the punishment is you have
to sit courtside at a wnba game and
actually watch the entire thing this is
by the way i have to tell you also that
i
for some reason
because this punishment is so funny i
fought for it like behind the scenes i'm
like this has to be we have to do this
um
and it only occurred to me after the
fact that i'll probably be the one who
loses because i'm terrible at fantasy
football so uh that's what's on the line
here that's why you need to tune in to
watch the draft party you can catch all
the draft action tonight over on crania
companies youtube channel at 7 p.m
eastern 6 p.m central now let's get to
our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we canceled jennifer lawrence
who's a hollywood actress been mostly
out of the spotlight since starring in a
series of flops over the last several
years now she's attempting to get back
into the spotlight again in the run-up
to the release of her latest film
and um having scrupulously studied other
hollywood actresses lawrence knows that
the best way to get the attention back
on yourself is of course to play the
victim card the fact that she has a net
worth of like 160 million dollars does
not at all hinder her in her access to
the victim card it's quite the opposite
effect as we will see
in an interview with vogue magazine
um lawrence runs through her list of
woes now
she begins with something that truly is
tragic and terrible and yet she manages
to find the least sympathetic possible
way to talk about it so she says that
she's suffered miscarriages
miscarriages are an awful thing we've
been through that in my family as well
but then she quickly adds that she was
planning to abort the first miscarriage
anyway in fact she frames the whole
conversation
around the dobbs decision explaining
that the the recent birth of her first
child
somehow has um
made her even more steadfast in her
support for abortion she says quote i
remember a million times thinking about
it while i was pregnant thinking about
the things that were happening to my
body and i had a great pregnancy i had a
very fortunate pregnancy but every
single second of my life was difficult
or rather different and it would occur
to me sometimes what if i was forced to
do this
now it's really hard to even fathom the
derangement in a statement like this
lawrence was pregnant with a child that
she said she wanted and yet took solace
in the fact that she had the option to
kill him
it's just the sort of thing that a
person should not feel comfortable
saying out loud but many such things are
said out loud in a culture devoid of
shame lawrence then goes on to attack
her own family speaking of being
shameless reading from the report and
variety it says according to vogue much
of lawrence's disappointment over roe v
wade began uh being overturned is quote
directed at certain relatives back in
louisville kentucky where she'd grown up
including her father the actor
had been trying to repair the family
rift after giving birth then the supreme
court ruling was made official and
complicated matters lawrence processed
her family drama in therapy quote i just
worked so hard in the last five years to
forgive my dad and my family and try to
understand it's different the
information they're getting is different
their life is different lawrence said
i've tried to get over it and i really
can't i just can't i'm sorry i'm just
unleashing but i can't f with people who
aren't political anymore you live in the
united states of america you have to be
political it's too dire politics are
killing people
she says i don't want to disparage my
family but i know that a lot of people
are in a similar position with their
families how could you raise a daughter
from birth and believe that she doesn't
deserve equality how
she doesn't want to disparage her family
but she will
this already tells you all you need to
know about this person i mean we don't
value loyalty very highly in this
culture mainly because we don't value
anything of value in this culture but
that doesn't let lawrence off the hook i
mean if you will attack your own family
in public
over political disagreements of all
things
that tells us that you are a
self-absorbed backstabbing brat but she
isn't done she also reveals that she has
sought therapy
over over a recurring nightmare that she
has involving tucker carlson and in the
same interview she for some reason
confesses that she she had her first
political awakening moment by watching
30 rock
and finally
following the script of every
self-victimizing woman in hollywood the
filthy rich jennifer lawrence complains
about her salary obviously
she says inequality is something rather
this is reading from vogue again or
variety any inequality is something
lawrence has had to contend with in
hollywood too where she has often been
paid lower than her male co-stars the
sony hack revealed that she has she made
far less than the likes of her male
co-stars on american hustle while
reports reveal in 2021 that she earned 5
million dollars less than leonardo
dicaprio on don't look up despite
sharing top billing with him lawrence
told vogue that all actors are often
overpaid but that doesn't make the pay
gap any less frustrating she added quote
it doesn't matter how much i do i'm
still not going to get paid as much as
that guy because of my vagina
well no jennifer it's not because of
your vagina it's because people are
more likely to see a movie for leonardo
dicaprio than for you
people will actually pay for a ticket
because they want to see dicaprio in a
film people will do that
i'm not sure anyone has ever purchased a
ticket just because they want to see
jennifer lawrence in a film and i think
she's a talented actress i just don't
think people are going to the movies to
see her
now technically her films have grossed
billions of dollars at the box office
but that's almost entirely due to hunger
games and x-men and those are both
franchises that would have had the same
success with literally anyone else in
her roles
that's the beauty of franchise films as
far as movie studios are concerned just
like plug anybody in and they'll make a
billion dollars
now we should also note that vogue
conducted this interview with her
first at an exclusive spa in santa
monica
and they had a follow-up at lawrence's
mansion in beverly hills so this is the
perfect picture
of modern victimhood you have a rich and
famous actress
lounging in her mansion wearing a
bathrobe which was what she was wearing
for the interview apparently while
complaining that she's oppressed by the
patriarchy because one of the top actors
in the business made a few million
dollars more than her on a film that
wasn't any good anyway
i think there is actually for the rest
of us though an important lesson in this
now we know that spoiled and pampered
people like to claim victimhood for
themselves and we know they do this
partially to virtue signal partially for
political points
partially because it's simply an
internal reflex that they barely
understand themselves but
at a deeper level i think
the constant self-victimization of
extremely comfortable people who live
luxurious
lives only goes to show that hardship
and struggle
are really necessary components of a
full and healthy life
they're so necessary that when a person
is insulated from hardship
they begin to like desire it they want
it
they make almost a fetish out of it
a life of unending comfort seems
meaningless to them and so they
find ways of convincing themselves that
they're persecuted
and they do this of course without
actually sacrificing any of the comfort
because they could give up all the
comfort and then really experience
margin but they don't want to do that
their commitment to suffering only goes
so far
but it does go just go to show that that
perhaps real hardship is is not always
something to be avoided
because the people who succeed in
avoiding it entirely
only end up wishing that they still had
it
and then they end up embarrassing
themselves
as jennifer lawrence has done here
and it's why she is today finally
canceled
and that'll do it for us for this
portion of the show as we move to the
members block i'll get used to ending
the show somehow eventually this way we
move over to the members block and uh
we'll see you there if not see you
tomorrow godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you